mechanics unions are strongly
criticizing American and Southwest
Airlines after our CBS news
investigation raised questions about the
oversight of aircraft maintenance we
interviewed more than two dozen airline
mechanics and reviewed years of FAA
documents u.s. aviation is currently
experiencing an unparalleled period of
safety but in the last few years the FAA
changed how it regulates Airlines Kris
Van Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington Chris good morning
good morning as part of this eight-month
investigation we found cases that raised
the question whether some FAA
investigators may be using different
interpretations of the same regulations
and a whistleblower office that can
identify problems but can't take its own
enforcement action the retribution
against mechanics we find problems in
interviews with 26 airline mechanics at
Southwest and American Airlines all
expressed concerns about undue pressure
to cut corners or not write up issues to
get planes back in service faster claims
consistent with FAA whistleblower
complaints and at least 32 anonymous
industry-wide reports since 2015 several
American mechanics agreed to speak on
camera but as we protect their identity
for fear of retaliation sooner or later
somebody's not gonna see something
because yesterday they were intimidated
by this 2015 FAA whistleblower
investigation substantiated allegations
American Airlines managers pressured six
Chicago mechanics to not record
discrepancies take short cuts or
improperly sign off on work which was
not actually completed warning it also
appears the concerns may be much more
prevalent across Americans organization
21 FAA follow-up investigations were
launched relying in part on the
airline's own internal reviews -
resulted in letters of Correction
mechanics have no place to go
Gary Santos is an American mechanic in
New York he says he's risking his job by
speaking to us on camera do you feel
like the FAA is doing enough in its role
as the oversight here to be policing
these
issues there in an enviable position
because they have to both police the
airline and promote the airline the fact
that mechanics can be harassed and it's
not considered regulatory violation that
that's a problem mechanics can file
complaints with their airline their
union or the FAA but the FAA office
investigating whistleblower complaints
can only recommend other offices take
follow-up action and we found
indications FAA investigators may be
interpreting regulations differently
some whistleblower complaints to the FAA
alleging mechanics were pressured were
substantiated essentially confirmed an
American but when different
investigators found similar behavior at
Southwest it was not substantiated
despite those investigators noting the
motivation behind management questioning
mechanics when they discover anything
outside the scope of a maintenance task
appears as a tool used to influence the
relaxing of standards to look the other
way shouldn't the FAA all be on the same
page about what the regulations are
that's the hope there was efforts 25
years ago to try to get the FAA
personnel consistent there's still
inconsistency even today the FAA was
putting a lot of faith in the safety
management systems of the airline of the
airlines
in 2015 the FAA moved from focusing on
enforcement to compliance and relying
heavily on the airline's own safety
programs to meet FAA standards since
2014 the number of enforcement actions
against Airlines has dropped roughly 70%
you think there's a willingness by the
FAA to come down hard on an airline the
inspectors in the FAA are out there
doing their jobs when they can do it but
then you've got the oversight or the
control of the top of the FAA saying
we're not gonna persecute we're not
gonna fire american in southwest are
currently in contract negotiations with
mechanics both say they do not tolerate
a hostile work environment and the faa
oversight system is working it's
important that everybody understand that
an american if it's not safe it's not
flying well have the highest confidence
in their in the work that our mechanics
do and also that any issue that's
brought up any issue is dealt with
appropriately
the FAA declined our request for an
on-camera interview but insists the
nation's aviation system is safer than
it's ever been saying in a statement to
CBS this morning
the FAA constantly works to improve
consistency say a safety data collection
and risk analysis the agency promises
swift and appropriate action if safety
standard violations are discovered
we should tell you the d-o-t Inspector
General is currently investigating the
FAA s oversight of maintenance programs
at Allegiant American in Southwest
Noren an important investigation and
great reporting there Chris by you and
the whole team thank you